dès qu'on va parler des jeunes ménages
au squat qui est plutôt sympa qu'on ait
place vendôme à paris c'est ambiance de
noël il ya des sapins de noël partout
c'est très sympa et surtout on va se
parler de ça je renonce pas d'un nouveau
véhicule alors que vous connaissez
peut-être je sais pas d'ailleurs
s'appelle links and co c'est une marque
de voiture qui appartient au groupe
volvo volvo à partie un groupe chinois
c'est une toute nouvelle typologie de
voitures qui est en train d'arriver en
france alors l'idée c'est du karcher et
c'est à dire c'est la voiture partagée
c'est quelque chose d'assez nouveau ici
aujourd'hui vous avez en gros trois
options la première vous aviez votre
véhicule un certain prix on a plus qu'un
repli l'euro que vous le dire dans
quelques instants cette voiture est à
vous vous pourrez l'utiliser comme bon
vous semble deuxième solution vous venez
vous l'a loué vous l'a loué 500 euros
par mois peut-être une petite somme tout
pouvait permettre de la mettre en
location pour toutes les personnes qui
auraient besoin d'un véhicule vous avez
une appli je vous montrais c'est
relativement simple pas encore bien
efficace encore aujourd'hui en france
mais ça existe dans les pays nordiques
ça c'est une solution qui est
intéressante et puis ensuite vous prenez
un abonnement et vous ne payez que
lorsque vous venez lourd et une voiture
vous à louer auprès d'un particulier
c'est ça c'est un nouvelle façon de
venir utiliser l'automobile dans l'idée
c'est plutôt sympa c'est plutôt sexy
c'est déjà en place dans les pays
nordiques ça commence à arriver ici
alors c'est vraiment tout neuf tout neuf
tout cas on va y aller doucement on va
commencer à regarder et à s'intéresser
de l'idc d'acheter une voiture vous
voulez louer auprès de particuliers
savent où la rentabiliser en tout cas
une partie vous pouvez louer autant que
vous
et pendant toute la semaine vous si vous
l'utilisez cole week-end voleur l'a loué
un ou deux jours lorsque ça vous
intéresse en particulier l'apprend il
vous l'a rend il ya un système de
notation l'idée plutôt pas mal à voir si
ça prendra oui ou non d'ailleurs des
pratiques qui vous envoie en commentaire
est ce que vous seriez prêt à louer une
voiture auprès d'un particulier link qu
est-ce que vous seriez prêt vous à louer
une voiture 500 euros par mois et à la
louer à différents particulier pourquoi
par contre ça peut être une idée de la
mobilité du futur autour de l'automobile
à bois
[Musique]
laissez-moi vous montrer comment ces
fichus à l'intérieur alors on s'installe
directement ici au volant on vient
démarrer son véhicule ici on vient
tourner son volant ça c'est pratique on
a déjà un écran ici qui vous servira de
pourvoir un petit peu ce qui se passe à
terre à votre véhicule et vous avez un
deuxième grand écran ici vous allez
avoir toute l'expérience logiciels alors
pour l'instant ici je vous ai rien mais
vous avez apple car pelé vous avez
android auto plus à votre navigation
vous avez tous qui est assez visible est
assez sympa ici donc lorsque vous mettez
de la navigation va vous le voyez vous
êtes tous directement sous vos yeux
assez peu de boutons ici franchement
c'est très simple un petit bouton pour
venir retourner au menu principal
connecte à trets parce que je suis sur
apple car play avec mon smartphone ça
marche bien je vois que là il ya une
raison à dispo voyez il ya des choses
qui commencent à arriver le réseau
commence à se déployer tout doucement a
vraiment tout doute tout doucement là je
peux me rappeler mon assistant qui
s'appelle franck c'est une femme elle ne
parle pas prendre tout de suite bon ben
voilà donc là vraiment normalement lier
franck si elle chauffant je peux venir
choisir à l'intensité de mai sièges
chauffants c'est vrai que ça c'est assez
pratique donc là il m'a remis apple car
plat et voyez directement liées comme ça
hop je veux sortir je vais voir ma
ventilation oui non quoi comment choisir
mon mode de ventilation c'est très
intuitif ans assure que c'est pas mal
ils ont assez bien bossé là dessus au
niveau de l'expérience logiciel on
comprend tout de suite où on et ça c'est
vraiment vraiment bien fait pareil pour
le réglage de la température je peux
choisir soit comme ça soit j'ai mon
petit bouton ici je peux dire même
synchroniser les deux si je le veux donc
c'est assez malin quelques petits
boutons rapide sur le dégivrage sur le
mode automatique pour l'air conditionné
pour la clio qui why not je suis en
commande automatique si j'aimais mode de
conduite à leur mode de conduite je
viens les choisir ici ça me change et
c'est une hybride donc je vais être soit
en hybride soit je vais passer à fond et
là je sens que le moteur a démarré l'âge
de son sous mes fesses à vivre ou alors
je me mets en pions et la pioche utilise
uniquement la consommation électrique
alors il faut savoir que par contre ici
vous avez à peine 60 kilomètres et
quelques là si vous voyez en bas c'est
écrit donc si je me mets en électrique
globalement je vais pas être très loin
67 km maximum les ne restent pas des
masses 44 donc c'est très clairement un
véhicule qui est fait pour rouler en
hybride on va se remettre dessus pour
pas voir de problème donc ça c'est assez
pratique assez peu de boutons de ce côté
là l'enam qu'ils commandent un petit
raccourci pour le multimédia c'est un
petit bouton play pause vous montez le
son vous le vc c'est vraiment
extrêmement minimaliste mais on a tout
ce qu'il faut le vent je trouve pas mal
hyper hyper confort à utiliser on
comprend assez vite le volume ici cette
commande là me servira à venir modifier
tout ce qui va s'afficher ici donc le
flux d'énergie ma navigation les média
mon trajet distance totale mon téléphone
brecht ou bien naviguer très très
facilement ici et si je peut activer
désactiver le micro monter le volume
baissé le volume lorsque j'ai passé un
coup de fil je suppose dépend
complètement utilisée mais ça me paraît
assez logique ici c'est pareil sur
pouvoir avoir mon limitateur de vitesse
régulateur adaptatif assistance routière
et surtout l'intérêt de ces véhicules là
c'est qu'il est basé sur indique 62
volvo et j'ai plein de petites options
je le vois ici à garder hop je descends
je peux venir activer/désactiver hybride
bright mode donc là je travaillais sur
un mode blanche mieux comme ça sur un
dark times c'est beaucoup mieux up reste
parle à mon petit lapin stationnement
semi-automatique caméra stationnement
arrière enfin bref j'ai accès à pas mal
de petits raccourcis vers des jeux comme
directive et ma caméra je trouve ça
vraiment bien fichu pour le coup aide au
stationnement aide au maintien de la
voix appellent clients paramètres de
connexion j'ai deux menus et je trouve
ça extrêmement bien fait c'est très
intuitif le menu la navigation les bien
fait et là vous avez un autre menu qui
est intéressant sur le côté vous allez
voir une boîte de réception des
informations sur votre voiture mais
surtout ce qui va être vraiment vraiment
pertinent c'est ce qu'on appelle le
carsharing c'est-à-dire venir partager
votre voiture donc vous dites que votre
emplacement et bien j'en sais rien moi
ici c'est 17 grande rue quand vous
rentrez votre adresse un peu importe
l'adresse de chez vous vous donner une
date de disponibilité du véhicule vous
dit s'il ya une heure de fin où ils
n'ont quoi comment et vous lancez le
partage et la vous avoir des
réservations est à vous voyez vous avez
un petit petit coin réservations alors
pour l'instant bien évidemment il n'y a
aucune réservation à venir mais lorsque
vous en aurez elles s'afficheront ici et
c'est là que vous allez venir lancer le
partage depuis directement l'interface
de votre véhicule alors après vous
pouvez sortir en appuyant là il vous
retrouvez votre menu état de la voiture
pression des pneus est talonnage de la
pression statistique de trajet flux
d'énergie on a quelques petites infos
qui sont relativement sympa journée
calme rare ok caméra de ses filles donc
là c'est une caméra intérieure plutôt
sympa on peut venir me voir comme ça je
peux vous parler directement bonjour
ayew sa caméra elle est là la caméra
également extérieur on peut faire des
photos on peut faire des selles fille on
peut faire des vidéos si on le souhaite
ok on a une galerie en accès aux
paramètres devront voir quelles sont les
différences journalistes qui sont passés
par là directement au quai salut les
gars navigation médias paramètres radio
bref voyez ce que ça vraiment
extrêmement intuitif et plutôt bien fait
après ici je veux voir trois petits
boutons pour tout ce que vous aller
enregistrer son utilisateur à la
position du siège de rétroviseurs et
compagnie mais petit bouton pour me
régler ici les fenêtres régler mes
rétros c'est très minimaliste c'est
simple ça fonctionne bien g du rangement
à peu près tous les côtés ici j'ai de
quoi mettre des petits gobelets encore
des petits heureusement ici donc voyez
l'habitacle je trouve quand même
relativement pas ma fille ici j'ai un
bouton qui est assez discret qui me sert
à ouvrir la boîte à gants j'ai de la
place je suis bien que sur une boîte
auto donc j'ai uniquement de petites
pédales bref le sens pas mal autre truc
qui est assez sympa j'ai un toit ouvrant
je peux venir soit complètement l'ouvrir
mais là je vous cache pas que la sakay
donc on va le refaire mais tout de suite
comme ça s'il était voulait profiter ben
vous pouvez le faire sinon vous venez
carrément fermer le toit voyez ma petite
trappe là qui remonte on va les laisser
ouverts parce que c'est quand même plus
cool d'avoir la lumière ce nouveau
trophée de la vidéo donc c'est une
voiture qui est toutes options dont vous
n'avez pas trente six mille solutions
vous dis pas tiens je vais m'acheter tu
me prend de telles options telles
options non elle est complètement inclut
la seule chose qu'on pouvait venir
module est ici et bien c'est la couleur
soit noir soit bleu ils ont fait
vraiment fait dans le côté hyper simple
nintendo vous avez une seule bagnols
vous avez le choix entre deux couleurs
elle est toute option donc là dessus
c'est vrai qu'on a ce qu'il faut à
l'arrière alors moi j'aimais mon pied
mais bon vous mettrez pas de pied au
moins vous voulez mettre des pieds si
vous voulez vous pouvez c'est assez
grand ça c'est quoi on peut venir qu'à
l'est des petits magazines je me
trouvais dans un avion là ok c'est assez
spacieux quand même hein il ya cette
place au niveau du coffre vous avez de
la place ici c'est la trappe on va venir
alors comment ce sont ces trucs comme ça
vous aviez imposées mais câble de
rechargement petite place aux côtés
surtout de l'audio est signé infinity
[Musique]
pour l'instant il tient qu en france est
extrêmement anecdotique vous avez quoi
70 véhicules qui sont dispatchés en
france alors tout l'intérêt d'une
solution comme celle là ça va être le
parc automobile parce qu'une voiture
neuve à l'aja c'est quand même 41 1500
euros donc soit vous l'achetez 9 mai à
ce moment là est ce que vous allez
acheter link1n cause je suis patient le
daily nk un coup au pouvoir louer un
véhicule facilement de pouvoir mettre en
location son véhicule facilement ce que
je voulais c'est quand même 500 euros
alors il faut savoir que ces 500 euros
par mois sans engagement mais vous avez
l'assurance compris vous avez
l'entretien vous avez les consommables
saad ehret pneumatiques et compagnie
donc si vous avez le moins de problèmes
500 euros c'est tout compris ça c'est
cool et en plus de ça au bout du 11e
mois ils vont vous proposer de switcher
sur le véhicule plus récente donc ça
vous permet d'avoir toujours la voiture
la plus actuelle donc l'idéal est quand
même vachement bien maintenant tout
repose sur la mise en place du réseau
parce que ça ne sert à rien de prendre
une voiture 500 euros par mois en disant
je veux la louer pour la rentabiliser si
en face de ça il ya personne qui la
loupe parce qu'elle pas encore
suffisamment voiture aucune raison n'est
pas développé alors c'est le tout début
de l'histoire j'imagine qu'ils vont
mettre en place des campagnes de
communication ci et ça pour faire
connaître les véhicules mais pour
l'instant on n'y est pas encore là on va
surveiller ça de très près et on verra
si ça va évoluer dans le bon sens ou pas
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que ça
existe déjà dans des pays nordiques dont
il ya aucune raison que ça ne se
développe pas en france après les tours
une différence de culture est ce que les
français sont prêts à louer leurs
véhicules est ce qu'on est prêt à
utiliser le véhicule d'un autre dans
quel état elle sera rendue essai sam ça
allez savoir un peu le truc qui est
intéressant c'est que la personne qui
loue son véhicule elle va garder 100 %
des revenus au cas rien qui tourne chez
link un co l'idée de linkin causé de
faire une location de longue durée sans
engagement en fait après vous avez une
application pour venir louer c'est
directement ici dans votre smartphone
alors links and co pour tout vous dire
aujourd'hui ça marche pas trop déjà les
monnaies c'est pas de l'euro alors c'est
pas très très grave aujourd'hui vous
voyez pas grand-chose voyage un petit
problème est quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas je vais dans mes
paramètres sherrington je peux venir
louer look et met la clim klaxonner le
flash donc à priori j'ai pas mal
d'options ici dans mon application met
tout de suite en tout cas ça ne semble
pas fonctionner donc ça me semble un
petit peu compliqué de vous montrer ça
donc à une application qui servira pour
le loueur est une application qui
servira pour la personne qui veut louer
je vais avoir un deuxième smartphone i
see you waiting donc là je pense que
c'est pour la personne qui va louer son
véhicule parce que là il ya des étoiles
donc on va avoir sa propre note on voit
quand est-ce que ça comment ça se
termine on voit la localisation on a les
détails méthodes de paiement je vois que
j'ai une mastercard tarifs d'assurance
bourges est quand même pas mal de
petites informations dans l'application
mais ça ne paraît pas encore il paraît
évident donc il est des mots est ce que
ces deux blocs différentes pour
l'instant je sais pas trop ce pas trop
clair mais ça c'est un truc qui va être
amené à évoluer de toute façon donc ce
qui est censé créer une application même
si pour l'instant il ya encore des bugs
et parce que le service n'est pas
développée en france et qui s'entraînera
probablement des modifs oncle système
implanté mais en tout cas l'idée est là
et sur le principe l'idée intéressante
bon le jour où ça sera vraiment étendue
au grand public pour un paquet de bugs
sinon ça pourrait rapidement poser
problème et puis s'il ya un dernier truc
à savoir qui est important c'est que ce
week end à mettre en location son
véhicule s'il lui qui fixe le prix c'est
lui qui décide y'a pas de prix de marché
alors après ça se régulera parce que
plus il y aura de monde et plus les prix
vont être concurrentiels parce que s'il
ya plus de personnes qui veulent louer
bien moment il va falloir être un peu
dans les clous c'est la règle du marché
mais voilà il n'ya pas de frais qui sont
fixées par linkin causé c'est vous qui
choisissez donc bon à voir ça peut être
marrant bon voilà je vais vous présenter
ce véhicule niveau technologique s'est
extrêmement bien maîtrisé on est sur une
base de volvo s60 et souvenez compatible
android auto apple car plaide donc en
terme d'automobile on a un truc qui
fonctionne bien c'est du haut de gamme
bien évidemment tant que point qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est de savoir est
ce qu'on est prêt à ces nouveaux
systèmes de mobilité ce qu'on est prêt à
venir partager son vécu est ce qu'on est
prêt à louer une voiture 500 euros en se
disant que un inconnu à venir l'utiliser
c'est un peu cette question qu'elle a
aujourd'hui c'est cette question un peu
de l'ubs et risation de l'automobile
ford la location est ce que ça pourrait
vous tentez ou pas vous tentez qu'est ce
que vous en pensez et le véhicule
tournoi y absolument aucun problème il
est vraiment très bonne facture très
belle qualité tous les services que vous
avez derrière que ce soit l'assurance
compris que ce soit à l'entretien sera
extrêmement rassurante 500 euros ça
reste un gros budget mais si vous
arrivez à le rentabiliser pourquoi pas
il faut voir je pense que pour
rentabiliser faut quand même le loup est
un peu donc il faut parler les besoins
qu'on a réellement par rapport à ça si
on n'a pas beaucoup de besoins est ce qu
on a beau parce qu'on a intérêt à les
louer auprès de quelqu'un ou est-ce
qu'on a intérêt à voir sa propre voiture
pour venir louer pour la rentabiliser
voyez ça se laisse plein questionnement
donc ça on regardera ça on va
s'intéresser on verra dans ces nouveaux
modes de consommation quand dites moi si
ça peut vous intéressez vous en bas en
commentaire à ce que vous seriez tenté
par acheter une voiture louer une
voiture vous m y est à disposition ou
alors absolument pas sur ce je vous
embrasse donne rendez vous très bientôt
on va continuer à parer d'automobiles
parce qu'il ya plein de choses qui
arrivent vous allez voir on va les
tester les voitures ça va être super
courant par terre sur la route fait un
bisou et puis je vous laisse ici à paris
on est aux invalides regardez comme
c'est mignon c'est sympathique il fait
presque beau il fait froid mais tout va
bien vous embrasse un gâteau tiens
[Musique]